[Music]
the single most stunning economic story
of the last few decades has been the
rise of china from 1980 to 2020 china's
economy grew more than
75-fold huge new cities were built
hundreds of millions escaped poverty it
was the largest and most rapid
improvement in material conditions on
record in modern history
let's go back
when the economist adam smith was
writing in the 1700s he considered china
to be one of the wealthiest countries
that had ever existed but after decades
of war and instability in the 19th
century and early 20th century china
began a rapid decline
up until a few decades ago china was one
of the poorest countries on earth but
now china is an economic powerhouse
economists predict that it will overtake
the us as the largest economy in the
world in this decade
people called it the chinese miracle you
can hear some people describe this
miracle as a straightforward story of
the free market they say it's a simple
story china was poor then the economy
was freed from the grip of the state now
china is rich
but this is misleading china's rise was
not about the triumph of the free market
to understand why we have to look at
what happened to other countries which
remade their own economies in the same
period often to disastrous effects
since the 1980s free market policies
have swept the globe
many countries have undergone
far-ranging transformations liberalizing
all prices privatizing entire industries
and opening up to free trade but many of
the economies that were subjected to
markets overnight have since stagnated
or decayed none have had a growth record
anything like the one seen in china
african countries endured brutal
economic shrinkage latin america
experienced 25 years of stagnation if we
compare china to russia the other giant
of communism in the 20th century the
contrast is even more staggering
under state socialism russia was an
industrial superpower while china was
still largely an agricultural economy
yet during the same period the chinese
reform led to it incredible economic
growth
russia's reform led to a brutal collapse
both china and russia had been economies
that were organized largely through
state commands
individual players could only act within
the structures set by state planning
think of playing foosball each
individual player can only be moved
along with the rod to which it is
attached
it is a wretched setup you can only go
back and forth or rotate
market reforms in both russia and china
was like moving from foosball to an
actual soccer game
players now could move freely but why
russia jumped right into the game
without setting up a proper stadium
rules or jury in china the state took
the lead in setting up all
infrastructure
the state built the team it trained the
players educated the coaches and
designed an overall strategy russia
followed the recommendations of the most
quote unquote scientific economics at
the time a policy of so-called shock
therapy
as a basic principle the idea was that
the old plant economy had to be
destroyed to make space for the market
to emerge
think of shock therapy like knocking
over at jenga tower after a short period
of pain russia was supposed to emerge as
a fully fledged capitalist economy
almost overnight
the leader of the plan announced it was
a way of destroying communism in russia
when russian president boris yeltsin
took power
he eliminated all price controls
privatized state-owned companies and
assets and immediately opened russia up
to global trade
so what happened
in a word
catastrophe the soviet economy was
already in disarray but shock therapy
was a fatal blow
the shock therapists had predicted some
short-term pain but what they did not
see coming was how severe destructive
and permanent the effects would be
consumer prices spiraled out of control
hyperinflation took hold
government coffers were looted gdp fell
by 40 percent
the shock therapy recession in russia
was deeper and longer than the american
great depression by a large margin this
was a disaster for ordinary russian
people
hiv infections
alcoholism childhood malnutrition and
crime went through the roof life
expectancy for russian men fell by seven
years more than any industrialized
country has ever experienced in peace
time in 2006 russian life expectancy was
still several years lower than it had
been in 1986 under the soviet union
it turned out that russia didn't get a
successful free market overnight instead
it went from a stagnating economy to a
hollowed-out wreckage dominated by
oligarchs
if simply getting rid of price controls
and government employment didn't make a
country prosper
and in fact destroyed its economy and
killed huge numbers of people
then clearly the rapid application of
free markets was not the simple solution
when deng xiaoping took over the
leadership of china in 1978
the country he inherited was still
desperately poor
in 1980 china had a per capita gdp of
just
194 dollars
that was less than sudan and haiti and
almost half of niger
the chinese leadership knew they needed
reform as i showed in my book how china
escaped shock therapy
throughout the 1980s the chinese
leadership repeatedly considered
implementing the same type of sudden
reforms that russia had pursued later
the idea of starting from a clean slate
seemed attractive
and shock therapy was widely promoted by
quote-unquote scientific economics
programs for rapid price liberalization
were prepared and then withdrawn
twice
but in the end they decided not to
pursue shock therapy unlike the free
market economists in russia
economists in china approached change
like a game of jenga
take out many pieces at once and the
whole thing falls apart take out
one piece at a time
and you can win the game instead of
knocking over the whole changa tower at
once
china reformed itself in an experimental
and gradual way market activities were
tolerated and actively promoted in
non-essential parts of the economy
china implemented a system of what they
called dual track pricing state-owned
enterprises and farmers had to deliver
their quotas to the government at a
certain price set by the government but
if they managed to produce more they
could sell their surplus at a market
price china was learning from the real
story of the world's most developed
nations countries like the united states
britain japan and south korea each of
these in their own way managed and
planned the development of the economies
and markets protecting early stage
industries and controlling investment
free market economists thought this
system would be a disaster
the american economist milton friedman
wrote an open letter to dung's premier
georgian he said that the dual price
system was a bad idea and that china
should quote free prices and wages in
one bold stroke end of quote just like
in russia but china's leaders didn't
listen and while russia collapsed after
following the shock therapy program
china saw remarkable success
the state kept control over the backbone
of the industrial economy as well as the
ownership over land as china grew into
the new dynamics of its economy
state institutions were not degraded to
faucets from the past but were often the
drivers at the frontier of new
industries
protecting and guaranteeing their own
growth
china today is not a free market economy
in any sense of the world it is a
state-led market economy the government
effectively owns all land and china
leverages state ownership through market
competition to steer the economy as a
whole
the shock therapy approach advocated
around the world was a failure while
russia collapsed after its sudden
transformation china's graduate reforms
allowed it to thrive
and that made all the difference
i'm isabella weber assistant professor
of economics at the university of
massachusetts amherst for the gravel
institute
[Music]
you